now another day another embarrassment
for vice president harris on the world
stage because during her remarks in
munich yesterday on the situation in
ukraine the vice president appeared to
be totally completely utterly unprepared
and she gave yet another rambling
incoherent answer falsely claiming
europe has been at peace for 70 years
take a look
we still
sincerely
hope that there is a diplomatic path
out of this moment
and within the context then of the fact
that that window is still opening all
the open although it is absolutely
narrowing but within the context of a
diplomatic path still being open
the deterrence effect we believe has
merit i mean listen guys
we're talking about the potential for
war in europe
i mean let's really take a moment to
understand the significance of what
we're talking about
it's been over 70 years and through
those 70 years as i mentioned yesterday
there has been peace and security
and of course it only got worse from
there as harris said sanctions would
absolutely deter putin despite also
saying that putin already made up his
mind to invade ukraine and just another
baffling contradiction so which is it
ask yourself uh what is all of this
turmoil going to do to energy costs
around the world rising gas prices a
40-year high of inflation we have now a
barrel of oil almost 100 bucks some
economists thinking might go to 150.
does the biden team have any solutions
any answers here with reaction former
hawaii congresswoman
tulsi gabbard is with us tulsi thank you
how did she say on sunday that she
believed sanctions on russian russia
would deter putin
and then on the other hand talk about
when america stands for principles that
we hold dear we put ourselves out there
in a way that we may incur some costs
we're already paying
a buck 50 more a gallon for gasoline now
we're gonna pay three dollars more for a
gallon of gasoline
yeah sean i i want to i want to focus on
those two points but first of all my
gosh this is embarrassing it's hard to
keep track of all of those jumbles of
words and it's clear that she was sent
there
to be the voice of the united states as
a purely political calculation you and i
both know she has no foreign policy
background no foreign policy
understanding she has no concept of the
cost of war nor does she have the temper
temperament necessary to be the voice of
the united states on the global stage so
it's embarrassing to see this play out i
want to talk about the two examples uh
that you raised there she talked about
deterrence and sanction
how do you how do you deter someone by
punishing them before they do it uh it's
it's very simple this is kind of like
grade school understanding where if you
say i'm gonna punish you before you do
something wouldn't a kid say okay fine
well i might as well go ahead and do it
anyway uh this this is not rocket
science here and secondly talking about
incurring costs and this one hits very
close to home because kamala harris and
joe biden have both said you know what
we are going to incur a cost
they're not going to pay the price
they're
multi-multi-millionaires both of them
the the power elite are not going to be
negatively impacted by this continued uh
escalation you know who will pay the
price it is hard-working americans all
across our country and frankly people
around the world who are already paying
the price and will continue to see
things worsen
this energy and gas crisis raising
prices as you mentioned we'll see those
continue to go up
we'll see that squeeze happening across
the country and around the world russia
is a major exporter of wheat we'll see
those costs increased around food
russia is also a major exporter of
nickel which is a major
element of of the electric vehicle
industry the list goes on and on about
the direct impacts that the american
people ourselves will have to pay as
well as the impact on the global economy
so really what they should be saying is
not we are going to incur costs they
should be looking directly at the
american people and saying you know what
you are going to pay the price for this
and yet they have not once justified to
the american people how their policies
and their actions actually serve our
best interests how they serve our
national security interests how they
serve our economic interest they have
failed to do that and the american
people will be left holding the bag
tulsi i want to be very clear i
absolutely positively do not believe in
any way
that the united states should be in
involved in this conflict but i do
believe that
we joe biden's energy and economic
policies created all of this a 40-year
high in inflation
on average about a buck fifty more a
gallon everything we pay for costs more
uh add to that this situation where
because we artificially reduced the
world's supply of energy that then
forced our allies right into putin's
hands and he now controls their destiny
the lifeblood of the world's economy you
had an interesting theory that if only
biden would have said no ukraine will
never be a part of nato you think it
might have been able to we might have
been able to prevent things that way
explain that part
uh it's really just looking at the world
through a very realistic lens sean it's
understanding the world that we live in
and not the world that maybe some people
wished existed and that reality is putin
has made very clear all along
that uh their security and his mind uh
is what's at stake here and they do not
want i don't want to interrupt us and
nato putin also said ukraine is not a
country
and he has been saying this going back
many many years so this has been these
territorial ambitions have existed
security component
they they have they go way back and they
they pre-exist this this uh moment that
we're facing but with regards to u.s and
nato just like we would not want russia
to come in and start putting their tanks
and missiles on our borders either with
mexico or elsewhere
russia says hey i don't want u.s and
nato coming and making their military
outpost on our borders within ukraine
guess what the united states doesn't
want that either nato countries don't
want that either so why not recognize
say hey this is something that actually
is common ground it is highly unlikely
ukraine will ever become a member of
nato let's take it off the table and
immediately that would de-escalate these
tensions and take that reasoning away
from putin for him to build up this
presence on ukraine's border might be a
little more suspicious than you in
believing that i think
this is very personal for putin and he's
taking this as this is russian land and
we will take it and how far he goes with
that i don't know by the way speaking at
cpac i was going to be there i had a
conflict i'm not able to go but uh
congratulations and i look forward to
watching your speech
thanks
all right thank you for being with us
hey sean hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to fox news youtube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else